for you and my daughter Margaery drink deep and
live long handsome go love my lord shall I call
your father shouldn't your grace not to have
it for long you ought to try enjoying something
before you die you might find it suits you not
now mace I win and I is speaking does this mean
I am a master of something now coins sheep's wool
Tywin and I already determined that I should be
the master of ships long before you the tyrannous
a great honest with being granted a seat on this
council begins this afternoon Otero be a good man
fetch my quill and paper I'm merely advising my
son until he comes of age and chooses a hand for
himself your grace I would be willing to serve
provisionally as the Kings hand until the King
has appointed you master of coin Oh your grace
he called your experience and wisdom in financial
matters unparalleled the honor is all mine your
grace the iron bank has called in one-tenth of
the Crown's debt how do we pay them house Tyrell
could front the gold and the the crown repairs
back in time or I'd have words of my daughter
we must send an envoy to the iron bank someone
of importance to show these bankers our respect
he's ordered ser Meryn to personally lead your
escort my very own Kings God music safe travels
will turn may I be the first to welcome you to
the free city of Braavos I hope your journey was
trouble-free bit of chop the last few days if we
come to a satisfactory arrangement be sure to say
the cast of The Arbors finest hallway I'm afraid
I don't partake there are not gamblers here at the
iron bank Lord Tyrell you're the world's best
gamblers and all those bets you won Belton yes
sir give me a kiss pile along and
give me two kisses in salty town
oh we're going to die caught that oh
[__] would never stop singing has
turned madness has overtaken this city
and burst in it stalls my children but
now we must drive it back under the rocks
whence it came but this vans had its day
[Applause] he's beaten that's what's happening I
will abandon the Tyrol name
and all that goes with it
faith is the way
[Music]